généralement le triathlon n'est pas le
sport qui vient naturellement la bouche
des enfants
c'est en voyant son père s'entraîner
callan brachet a voulu suivre ses traces
il le lance tout d'abord dans la
natation avec les bébés nageurs et des
cas là n'a pu y participer
il s'est aligné sur l'épreuve à
seulement sept ans sur les premières
compétitions en natation quand il était
tout petit quand il était à venir ils
gagnaient déjà donc les autres voyaient
alingue comme un extraterrestre pourtant
il n'était pas grand elle n'était pas
super grand par rapport aux autres
pour sa première terminator n'a pas
gagné en quelque sorte l'exception qui
confirme la règle car huit ans plus tard
allan a accompli le grand chelem
champion de france minimes de tri
appelons de duathlon et d'aquathlon il a
également régné sur les championnats du
monde scolaires à porto rico
une performance inédite dans l'histoire
du tri français qui ne semble pas
rassasié le jeune colosse bien au
contraire
au fur et à mesure des compètes des
compétitions du coup bah j'ai la
fondation nager plus vite ou de rouler
plus vite pour certaines ou même
certaines courir encore plus vite
sachant qu'il procure et ben ça me fait
toujours plus avec ce sens la seule en
fait c'est politiquement incroyable
c'est quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
fait quand quelque chose qui n'a jamais
été fait arrive selon des surprises 11
il va pas y arriver si alagna donc fait
c'était le plus surprenant c'est ce
catalan chez lui et il fait ça avec une
décontraction déconcertante
il fait ça naturellement il va pas au
delà on a on lui a pas demandé d'aller
au delà de ses performances il a pas ce
qui s'est pas entraîné plus que
d'habitude son avenir sur les podiums
dépendra de sa course à pied pour
l'instant la machine survole la natation
et le vélo mais il doit encore
progresser dans la troisième épreuve
malgré une pointe de vitesse moyenne de
18 km heure par rapport au niveau
mondial les meilleurs chercheurs par
très bon dieu et bah du coup j'ai fait
une
vraiment nous rapprocher pour ensuite
plus tard l'eba donc dans l'objectif
c'est plus tard d'être aux jo et faire
une grande possibilité de médaille
cette nouvelle saison va déjà être
révélatrice pour alan brachet passant
chez les cadets les distances de course
vont doubler le chemin est encore long
on le nouveau diamant du tri français